i'm just so used to being attacked for
everything i say
it's like at this point i'm like all
right you know what what are you gonna
do you're gonna call me a mean name
what would that feel like what would it
feel like to see myself called something
horrible in every newspaper
in the country oh wait i've done that
so what was it like for you to sort of
be someone that was supposed to be
talking about the news
but also for a lot of the time you were
you were kind of making news i mean
everyone knows the
what happened with trump and and the the
debate
um but that you sort of got sucked into
news too
and in the movie there's a line where um
nicole kidman as as you basically says
that you know no no charlize theron
oh sorry uh charlie's thrown where she
says um
you know that she you basically saying
you know
you didn't want to be making the news i
assume that's pretty
i didn't want to be the story yeah yeah
i said i'm not going to be the story and
i don't want to be the story
and and i was the story after that
debate and then i
hated it and i have hated being the
story every time it's happened
you know i see journalists as as you
know on the sidelines
not as players on the field and um
you know trump to some extent grabbed me
and put me on the field
and the roger ailes thing did too and
then just i don't know once you get
well known you know the sleazy media
takes a big interest in you and starts
following you around and
they're not all bad some guys are good
there was actually a sweet guy
right after i left nbc all these
paparazzi were outside of my apartment
and um
you know i couldn't like leave without
getting and this one guy he was from the
post
he got his shot he's like and then he
goes this is such [ __ ] megan you
can't say anything anymore
so like there are real people out there
they're not
all bad but i don't like being the topic
of the news
i i have asked myself many times why
that keeps happening you know
i think um i think people aren't used to
seeing like
somebody they can't figure out somebody
who's sort of
unapologetically strong um especially
especially
a woman that we're out there but like
it's not that common
and um a woman who doesn't mind fighting
right like it's like what what's what's
she doing
well you know that i'm futilistic by
nature and i think it
it may be exciting it may be upsetting
you know it may be alienating but for
whatever reason
it's attractive news yeah it's funny to
me because
as you're getting back into the fray
like it's so obvious there's going to be
a moment
like within a couple months where
something's going to happen
like you're going to say something or
one of your guests is going to say sorry
and you're going to be like oh why did i
get back in but then but then an hour
later you'll be like this is exactly why
i got back in like that's just the
negotiation
i don't think that's going to happen to
me i mean i do think they're going to
come after me you know knives out but
i'm just so used to being attacked for
everything i say it's like at this point
i'm like
all right you know what what are you
gonna do you're gonna call me a mean
name
what would that feel like what would it
feel like to see myself called something
horrible in every newspaper
in the country oh wait i've done that in
a way it's sort of empowering because
it's like
they they took their best shot i'm here
i'm well
i'm happy i'm about to launch something
that i'm really into
and for once dave like they can't get
rid of me
they can't get rid of me you know like
even if every sponsor i have is like
we're out then i'll do subscription you
know the relationship will be between me
and my audience
and they can't stop it whether they want
to or not they can't stop it i will
have my say i will have these
discussions with interesting provocative
people
people who go against the grain and if
the audience is there
i will remain on the air you're speaking
my language sister
i i may be able to retire i may be able
to retire early now that you're getting
back in
what do you mean we're going to go off
to the sunset together in the digital
sunset
the digital sunset there you go um all
right so let's talk
a little bit about just like generally
what's going on in the world right now
um you know the the the racism stuff
the the the riots the protests
we'll get to kobit in a sec what do you
make
about what is happening here it seems to
me that we're just sort of watching the
entire fabric
that we've had here for 200 you know
almost 50 years
basically unravel that that just sort of
this idea that this whole thing was
founded on racism
and that's the driving force behind
everything it strikes me as so dangerous
and yet it's so sort of accepted which
is kind of what you were saying before
about
uh that that the left seems to have
taken so much control of this stuff
what do you make of what's happening
right now with race and the conversation
well i think it's very frustrating for
people like me
like you who would like to be allies
to people of color to black people
anybody who feels ostracized and
suffers from racism and yet there's no
way in
without somehow completely embracing
the insane messaging from a group like
black lives matter
i think most normal people believe there
is racism
in the country but that we are not a
racist country
and that and they don't believe we were
founded on racism and even
even the new york times with this 1619
project is slowly withdrawing
all those names from a piece without
highlighting the withdrawal they're just
like oh never that stuff we said about
being founded on racism and the whole
point about like
you know keeping slavery never mind
eraser
which is so dishonest that's literally
happening yeah
literally for a news organization not to
call attention to the deletion
that's a massive deletion and it caused
a lot of controversy
and they're just slowly taking it down
it's not true the country wasn't founded
to hold on to slavery and it isn't a
racist country it did used to be
you know i mean back in slavery jim crow
we had massive problems
but the thing that bothers me about
what's happened over the past few months
is it's based on a lie it is based on a
lie
not the george floyd case that was
disturbing and that case will play out
appropriately in the court
but the lie that police are
systemically and as a group hunting
black people it isn't true
and even you know i think that was the
term lebron james used you know
something about how a black
person or black man can't even go
outside where they're getting hunted
wrong and the data are there and the
people who
cite the data get just so malign but if
you look
like here in new york in the 1970s the
murders per year that the shootings
uh per year were in the 400 400 plus
a couple years ago they were down to
like 36 right so it's like
the top the behavior is going in the
right direction there are some bad
apples we all know that in any
profession there are
right certainly in our profession um
if you look at the actual data of the
number of black
unarmed men because it's always men uh
who get killed by police uh compared to
their number of interactions with police
their crime rate
um it's not disproportionate right
because the studies will show in jason
riley of the wall street journal
who is black has been doing a great job
covering this
that over 50 of the violent crimes are
committed
by black men and that is why they have a
higher interaction rate with police in
part
and therefore the stakes go up right the
stakes go up for
because given the history between them
it's fraught
for a negative encounter and then for
potentially something deadly to happen
i'm not saying it's good
i'm just saying you can't attribute it
to racism without factoring in
crime rates if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell